welcome to dc thursday i'm pete
soderling i'm the founder of data
council and the data community fund
i am your guide through the vast and
rapidly
changing data ecosystem
as you know here on dc thursday we chat
with
founders and open source leaders and
other types of thought leaders in the
data community
and i'm very excited to introduce eric
sammer who's our guest today
eric sammer i can say is not just a
colleague from the data ecosystem over
the past number of years but he's also
become a friend
uh eric is legendary in the data world
uh he is currently the ceo and founder
at decodable which is a company bringing
a modern streaming approach and product
to market
before that eric was the co-founder and
cto
at log analysis company rokhana
which sold to splunk
where eric became a distinguished
engineer
prior to that he spent time at cloudera
magnetic in new york which is perhaps
where we first ran across each other
and uh and additional companies
are on eric's resume
so eric
welcome to the show i'm really glad that
you're here
i am super excited to be here too i i'll
have to admit that like these intros
they embarrass me you know so so you've
sufficiently embarrassed me we're off to
a good start
awesome
well um don't don't blush too much uh we
have a lot to cover
and uh obviously we'll be talking a lot
about streaming today which has been
your focus for the past number of years
um
excited to sort of dig in and see how
that's developed across the course of
your career
and i want to acknowledge the audience
the live audience that's tuned in
we take questions from them to the
extent that they put them in the chat
and we have time to cover them so i want
to invite the folks who are listening
out there who have questions for eric
about his his career about streaming
systems um what other other questions
you have in general about data to feel
free to jump in the chat and
we'll get to those as we have time
so eric um
i noticed when i was looking at your
profile that
uh
you don't have a degree listed on your
profile and some people do that for
various reasons and
um you know
some people don't want to lie about a
degree that they don't have which you
know
sometimes becomes a thing on linkedin
and people get get get caught for but
tell us um is is there a story there
like how did you
how did you sort of get into tech and
and tell us about the your education and
or the early parts of your career
because i'm curious to hear that story
yeah yeah i you know some people have
asked about this i always think it's
really funny um so i mean the short
answer is i don't have a degree
um you know i am
[Music]
self-taught you know most of my
education in tech has been
sort of what i would think of as like a
prolonged internship that you know uh
that happened over the course of like
many different companies and like lots
of people who were willing to spend time
with me on things um and
uh sitting on the floor of barnes noble
so for those of you sort of like under
the age of 40 there used to be these
places that actually have these things
called books and we put words on pages
and stuff like that but you know i uh
you know i spent a large portion of my
my teenage years camped out on the floor
of you know bookstores reading books
that i i couldn't afford and then
putting them back on the shelf um you
know and sort of coming back so i uh i i
actually um
for a variety of reasons most of which
are probably not you know uh
you know worth sharing here but
i actually end up dropping out of high
school um and i was a music teacher
working recording studios and stuff like
that
and uh teaching
piano bass guitar and drums stuff like
that and then working in recording
studios um and got into
my my first exposure to like programming
was actually like uh digital signal
processing systems and stuff like that
and sort of like you know digital audio
and
and those kinds of things
um everything from like synth
programming sort of follow it through
you know
various other kinds of systems
specialized languages and stuff like
that um
and
you know again like you know i'm i'm old
so like this is
the late 90s
and like the dot-com thing was happening
and
anybody who could write any kind of code
just like instantly got jobs and stuff
like that so i wound up
looking into
you know my first tech job which was
actually tech support right like it was
a nice sort of on-ramp you know into
into tech
and then you know through a series of
companies that
you know were willing to either take a
chance on me or
you know and or great mentors along the
way like i wound up picking up a bunch
of programming languages and like
increasingly
got experience running data centers and
like working on oracle databases and
like eventually started like getting um
into actually building database systems
um in the ad tech space you know um and
and getting more and more experience you
know
initially as analytics and then also
like ad targeting and behavioral
targeting systems and stuff like that
and
you know
i think for me
it all sort of like really cemented
you know i was probably about nine or
ten years into my career
uh a little bit longer i guess um
toward the uh
like 2009 or so and like this weird
thing called hadoop started to get like
a little bit popular and people were
talking about map the map reduced paper
out of google and stuff like that i'd
always like follow you know
as much as i could sort of like you know
was a voracious reader of like academic
papers and stuff like that um
because like that's where i learned
about stuff right i didn't didn't get
the chance to go and study in school and
stuff
and
you know
uh
wound up sort of finding my way to this
very very small company called cloudera
at the time
and
i looked at the team page
and like
i was blown away
by
like the the the experience and like the
background of like all these different
people they were like phds from like you
know this place and like
stanford and uc berkeley and like you
know mike olson was like postgresql like
you know like
illustrator and like all these other
things i was like i
want to work on this hadoop stuff and i
want to work with this team
and
i emailed you know then ceo
uh
christopher siglia and and just said
like like
you have to hire me and here's why
you know and it was like a super
obnoxious email and like he called my
bluff and he said like there's this
conference called hadoop
hadoop world you know and you should
come join
and i met aaron kimball and like a bunch
of the other early you know clutterer
folks at the conference and interviewed
i think sitting on the floor you know in
some like really small hotel it was like
200 person conference and it was like
2010 or something
and uh
and they they
offered me a job you know after
teaching some courses for them and sort
of meeting a bunch of different people
that were affiliated with the company
interesting
yeah i don't i don't i don't think i've
ever heard that version of the story and
i have to say
you just touched on
three things that are all like
particularly meaningful for me
being a self-taught programmer a
musician
which i also am
and sort of getting opportunities um
obviously in data through the conference
world
um i mean could could there be a a more
perfect story for the show i'm not sure
no probably not i and i think that's why
i sort of like love
you know
uh you know stuff like data council and
like the sort of like all these slack
groups and and conference circuits and
like stuff like that because like you
know
the the meeting the people and sort of
like sucking up all the knowledge and
stuff like that you know that to me was
like a huge catapult for my career and
like i just love being part of it
that's amazing and for for bonus points
um
this is a secret dream of mine i've
thought that we should have like bring
our instruments um because so many
engineers are musicians
or ex-musicians or whatever i've often
thought that there's this subtext of
data council which i don't really talk
about
very publicly because it's just sort of
this personal like fantasy this dream is
to like have us all bring our our our
instruments and have a jam a jam room or
a jam session like how amazing would
that be
you know you know you know we're all out
there we're all like in this community
like wanting to do something like that
yeah you know there is a dirty secret
that i once did a radio jingle for money
and
you know in the very sort of early days
where i was like man i'm gonna make a
career out of being a musician i'm like
that was the first gig that i got and i
did it and i got paid for it and it
ruined music for me for like the next
six months
and i vowed to never make music for
money ever again funny funny well as far
as i got was this jar on top of the
piano
um you know at the local restaurant but
that's yeah we're getting way off base
here so yeah sorry um this this this is
awesome
um so you ended up at cloudera which was
a small company at the time uh what were
you working on
yeah so initially i actually joined
clutter you know honestly i would have i
would have taken out the trash for
you know for the chance to work with
that team i've always just kind of been
that person so as much as i wanted to be
on the engineering team i was in new
york they were in at the time burlingame
you know this tiny little office and
burglaring game uh out in the bay area
and
they said to me like well would you be
willing to like you know do
training sessions for people and you
know basically do professional services
like so fly around and like i had this
background in data center operations and
stuff like that you know and sort of
building and deploying at the time
racking and stacking machines like a
lost art you know at this point um
and you know they said like well would
you be willing to like fly around and
hang out with customers and help them
build out these big hadoop clusters and
i was like yeah sure you know like
whatever you know take out the trash
build build hadoop clusters who cares
um and i did
and i spent about a year or so
um flying around and and sort of living
on site with
you know
i won't get into names you know just
out of respect for those companies and
and and cloudera's privacy and stuff
like that but you know uh let's just say
the fortune 500 you know sort of like
banks and retailers and sort of all
these different people and living inside
of you know cold data centers and then
sort of hot offices you know configuring
these hadoop clusters
um
and
got like a ton of experience in sort of
seeing like what made hadoop tick and
what worked and what didn't and
um
eventually like just got sick and tired
of traveling you know like it's a rough
life it
requires a certain kind of person
um and then after about a year or so of
doing that you know
uh
my wife and i decided to move out to you
know move over to the dark side so we we
moved from new york city to
to
san francisco
and i moved into at the time uh you know
an engineering role you know on the on
the team over at clutter and then worked
on like a bunch of different projects i
worked on
you know flume i worked on
you know uh for a period of time i
managed the team that that was
responsible for you know uh
parquet and avro and sort of like did
you know a bunch of stuff there honestly
like like i said i would sort of do
whatever the team asked me to do
you know uh
you know uh
just to sort of
be part of that experience uh and wound
up staying there for about four years
almost to the day
so i left in 2014 to start rokhana with
two other two other folks from from
cloudera as well got it got it and so
what was the like first of all what
possessed you to
start a company as an engineer
um and
i also sort of you know when i have the
opportunity i ask folks about the the
early funding like did you get involved
in the funding process because this is
something that's particularly
challenging for those of us with
technical backgrounds oftentimes is sort
of knowing how to navigate the funding
world the big bad world of vc et cetera
et cetera so tell us about the early
years and sort of what possessed you to
kick off this journey in the first place
and how it went
yeah bad decision-making and
day you know like just like you know
uh no i mean
so you know after about four years at
cloudera like we had seen
the kinds of things that people were
building on top of hadoop right like
what were the business cases what were
the applications what what was it
supporting right like yeah it was big
data and like all this stuff but like
what were people doing with it
and increasingly it was like machine
data it was basically logs and events
and like all these other kinds of things
and so we got
you know people were building like the
inside joke was like you know it was
like a poor person's you know
splunk you know it was like one of the
sort of big use cases and so we
you know
focused around that use case of what
folks these days would call
observability and you know sort of like
logs and metrics and you know tracing
wasn't really like a thing at that time
but it was a lot of that kind of stuff
um
and i had
in 2011 and and i think it was released
in 2012 i had written a book for
o'reilly so like we had a little bit of
street cred around
you know hadoop and big data and like
all these kinds of things and in 2014
you know clutter was like certainly like
one of the marquee companies it was the
hotness and so it was the right time to
you know go out there and try something
and i'll tell you that like
it is terrifying as an engineer without
like an mba go raise a bunch of money
you sort of like live in this world of
like this soup of acronyms and words
that don't mean anything to you you have
to you know you know that any bad
decision
like kind of like put you in it like in
a bad spot for like the next however
many years
um
luckily i had two co-founders that were
a little bit more savvy than than i was
you know about the stuff so don brown
and and armor time and you know uh who
are also clutterer folks
um
we started the company and honestly i
think we were drafting on
uh cloudera's name and sort of the
hadoop sort of wave and stuff like that
and you know wound up raising i think it
was four and a half million dollars from
general catalyst and
it was
good size at the time
at the time yeah we called it a series a
uh
it was a pretty big
round it was a big bet on the behalf of
the team over a general catalyst you
know who is a great fund for sure
um
and uh i gotta tell you like
you know it sounds silly but like it was
pretty it was pretty easy
you know to to raise that money
um
i'll tell you these days
you know the options for raising capital
and like the resources
to learn about the ins and outs of
racing capital are just like
intensely
um
helpful
you know and like again it's a network
effect right there's no shortage there's
no there's no uh replacement for sort of
having people that can sort of connect
you to the right people by the way like
if anybody's interested in this like i
love helping companies sort of like
figure this stuff out especially like
commercializing open source and sort of
like figuring out like those kinds of
things to spend a bunch of time thinking
about this
um
you know
uh and sort of watching people be
successful in this space i think that
engineers starting companies are just
like so connected to product you know um
in such a deep way and and so much
of
you know these great companies are like
very technical in nature they actually
benefit from having sort of engineers
who are willing to kind of color outside
the lines and and go start that company
take that on it's it's not as scary
honestly as you know
as debugging c plus compiler errors i'll
say that like you know i mean like
you know given the things that we
learned you know yes it's like this like
you know big scary thing but it turns
out that it's pretty straightforward
you know there's the the right sort of
hack if you will is to surround yourself
with people who you can ask questions
and like who have been there and kind of
down there done that there's no
good owner's manual for starting a
company and like raising capital that
that isn't you know um
like a sales pitch you know so
having those people i think for me was
like the biggest advantage and i still
use i still keep a network of folks uh
including you you know who sort of
advised me in sort of various capacities
so
um so that's actually been immensely
helpful it's yep
it's a scary experience but i got to
tell you it's
it's some of the most fun
i've ever had
you know for sure
yeah there's nothing quite as
challenging as starting a company
that's yeah that's right and you get to
work with all these smart people um
which is just in itself its own reward
um yeah that's that's what's got me
going over the years as well and i'm
starting my own startups and working
with founders like you and um and
filling a community you know full of
those folks that data council um it's
been it's really been an honor and
a pleasure
um so so what about streaming like
there there must have been i mean
obviously there were streaming
implications of what you were building
at rokhana and this is when like you
said 2014 or 15 or so yeah yeah so talk
to us about sort of how you got into the
streaming world and and what that meant
um at least in the rakana case yeah i
mean
you know our our sort of thinking with
rocanna was
you know to allow people again like it's
sort of like that the classic big data
thinking is like well if people could
capture more data and they could retain
it and then they could analyze it like
they could sort of have better sort of
visibility into things um
you know i won't give you that pitch um
i think we've
we've learned more about some of that
stuff but
um
a large portion of that was actually
based on
you know making as much of the system in
the analytics uh real time right so like
there was advantage especially in
observability to like detecting either
threats faster or detecting incidents
faster and stuff like that
um
and being able to do you know take like
automated you know remediation type
actions and stuff like that you know
shut down attacks or or spin up
containers or whatever the case may be
um
so a lot of rokana's
system was based around sort of like
real time streaming stuff it was very
much like
kafka internally so it was like sort of
the early days of kafka i guess um
or early you know maybe the middays of
course
um
but you know we were very kafka centric
we you know at the time spark streaming
wasn't as you know robust and i don't
know that flank was totally a thing at
the time
um
and so we had actually built a bunch of
stuff and sort of directly on the kafka
apis and things like that eventually
you know uh we realized that we could
replace a bunch of that with with uh
spark or flink we would end up choosing
uh flank in the end for a variety of
reasons and then that was by the time we
sort of had gotten there
you know uh we wound up being acquired
by splunk so i was like 2017
and we were we were using flank and
starting to get more and more into flank
and so that basically left us with and
in fact the most successful part of
rokhana i mean that's like a whole other
story but like the most successful part
of rokon was actually its data
infrastructure was was the real time
sort of pieces of that like you know
full disclosure like or sort of
transparently we like missed the product
market fit you know on on rokana but we
actually end up building a bunch of good
technology
we had a handful of customers you know
like i said that's a whole nother story
but you know uh we were acquired into
splunk and you know at the time splunk
was like thinking a whole lot about how
to
um
again like i don't want to talk too much
about the internal spunk or publicly
traded and stuff like that but you know
what i'll say is that like you can
imagine that uh being able to detect
threats faster being able to
prepare data for query those kinds of
things are just like natural sort of use
cases
for
stream processing um alerting all these
other kinds of things that sort of can
be done on the stream
and a lot of like
the problem of observability like
anybody who's deployed any of these
systems splunk or otherwise knows that
like just the function of like getting
data into the system in the right format
and extracting the right fields and
enriching it the right way which is all
just like a a purpose-built use case
around like
uh streaming etl right like there's no
sort of like nice window dressing on it
it's basically etl
um that stuff will end up becoming
really really valuable and certainly
splunk had a lot of infrastructure there
already like we worked to sort of build
on on top of
you know
excuse me what the what the team had
already done there for sure
so you know
but uh
yeah so i i mean that that's what i
think really got me deeply involved in
streaming so from about 2014 up until
now my whole universe has been like
real-time streaming engines and
messaging systems and got really focused
around that side of the world got it
and so
i mean you are definitely the the
resident data council streaming expert
and you have been for years and you know
that i come to you with all questions
about all things streaming it
automatically like hits your inbox
um
so so thank you for that
um in addition it seems like the world
hasn't quite
woken up to streaming data yet um a lot
of vcs are kind of
you know watching with one eye they're
not sure how big of a market maybe it's
going to be there's you know
um there's lots of opinions about
streaming in in the space what do you
think about sort of the market readiness
for streaming um and maybe the the only
way to really answer that is to is to
answer like why hasn't streaming caught
on yet or why isn't it why don't we do
more amazing things with the streaming
architecture that we've had for the last
five years like what's what's going on
in the market
you know so i think it's um i hear this
a lot
you know part of me like wants to like
push back on it but like the reality is
like certainly relative to like batch
data processing or sort of you know even
like micro batching and stuff like that
you know it's just true
you know and i think like we just need
to own this as the streaming community
and say like yeah it's like hard you
know it shouldn't be what it is um it's
hard
it's hard um
so a couple of things one
i think we you know we got to look at
why is it hard and
i've spent a lot of time thinking about
this i gotta tell you that
there are
very smart people smarter than me for
sure
working on and thinking about the
internals of the engines right like how
to make the the engine lower latency how
to better sort of think about uh
partitioning and sort of query planning
and those kinds of things
you know
i will say that like left to its own
devices like that
stream
forgive the pun of sort of work will
continue to evolve and get to better and
better places right the technology will
sort of get there the issue i see with
real-time data engineering or stream
processing and stuff like that is just
what it asks of developers
you know one of the big things that made
hadoop
kind of fall away in favor of you know
system like arguably more traditional
systems like snowflake or redshift and
bigquery and like all these other kinds
of things the reason why i kind of wound
up getting its butt kicked over time was
just because like it was too low level
and i don't think that we were
insightful enough uh honest enough to
look at it and go like nobody in their
right mind
wants to be thinking about java class
loaders and
you know spill
tuning and like all these other kinds of
things the streaming equivalent of that
is like oh my god any more conversations
about messaging guarantees at least once
and most once exactly once like
you know
we talk way too much about that i mean
like it's important it's critical it's
got to be right but like nobody in their
right mind wants to be operating at that
level right like it's out it's incumbent
on us as like the people who build these
kinds of systems to elevate away from
that you know
the same way people in the data
warehousing world don't want to be
thinking about blockchaining
and like you know
you know all of the kind of like stuff
that we used to think about with like
relational database systems and data
warehousing and you know in sort of the
olden days you know they want cloud
systems nobody wants to run clusters
anymore you know bless their souls you
know and the streaming world like
messaging guarantees
uh event time versus processing time
like these are core critical concepts
but like they're just too damn
complicated skew and partitioning and
like all these other kinds of things
um
retention times job recovery
how to handle schema changes
you know what to do about malformed data
like
you know we need to up level
you know the abstractions and sort of
what we're offering to people and like
look i i just don't think
you know the impetus for decodable
you know was really just like even with
the tools that exist today and like
again i don't want to bad mount these
tools right we're standing on the backs
of giants you know the shoulders of
giants flink spark
k streams
you know all these kinds of systems
through great systems
but they're really low level systems
it's like building
a an e-commerce application
using only assembly and like sys calls
like just nobody wants to do it and i
think that
that is the barrier
you know
if you ask any and including like all
the people that we talked to at the
incredible you're just like so like what
does streaming look like and they're
like well
it's complicated so we start with batch
and i think that like that encompasses
like the entirety of the problem it's
like
it's just seen and in in a lot of cases
it is more complicated than just like
airflow plus deeply dbt plus snowflake
you know and so like that's fine i'll
just do that and like you know and
again i also don't think that
it's streaming versus batch i actually
think like again another discussion but
these things there's there's this
religious war between these two camps
and like i just
like let's be more pragmatic than that
like there are cases where if data is
leaving germany and you want to mask
like pii and phi data like let's do that
in the stream if you want to like
you know curate and build like at rest
training data sets for ml models let's
do that in batch like you know i just
don't think we need to get too wrapped
around the axle about the stuff there's
plenty out there for us
um
but i just think we need to up level
sorry that's like a whining answer about
that
i could rant about that i get it and and
i actually want to come back to the to
the streaming versus batch or streaming
plus batch um
discussion later
um but the but you know the one thing
that i take away from
all of your comments when i chat with
you about this space is i just
appreciate how
developer focused
sort of user experience developer
experience focused you are and
i think it's it's sort of been obvious
through your career as you've been
getting more experienced yourself
in this low the the lower level tools
that are behind the streaming systems
and it seems like you have a heart to
you know start start to build on top of
that and as you said abstract a lot of
that complexity away
um and it it seems to me like you just
described decodable you can you can
describe decodable again for the for the
listeners but yeah i heard you say that
um you built some amazing infrastructure
at rakana didn't have product market fit
but you probably learned a lot about
building
easy to use or easier to use robust
streaming systems and it sounds like you
know what i would infer from that is
that you want to sort of take a lot of
these lessons out to the world and and
reduce the complexity of streaming um
for the average engineer
yeah i mean certainly that's our goal i
mean
my sort of utopian view of this after
having talked to
like the entirety of like the global
2000 as well as like small startups and
stuff like that
is just that
most engineers just never want to see
a java class loader or talk about you
know zookeeper and like z nodes and like
you know quorums and those kinds of
things they never want to deal with that
level of stuff
instead like
but when you talk to them about like how
they interface with something like
postgrads or mysql or you know you know
any of the sort of cloud versions of
that like aurora and so on and so forth
from you know from amazon you know
um
they don't even like think about it
they're like oh like we'll just use
postgresql like everybody in the room
just kind of nods and like you know they
move on with life we need to make
streaming look like that
you know that's what it needs to look
like it just needs to be like oh we'll
just you know do this thing
and like when you look at how
there's a lot of work to be done on the
engines and serialization formats and
sort of messaging systems and stuff like
that don't get me wrong
but there are lots of smart people
working on that problem the thing that
we're trying to do
is up level the effectively like
you know make it user accessible
and that is basically make the cluster
disappear
make the you know sort of like all the
sort of like technical pieces you know
the the infrastructure pieces disappear
so that the customer is left with
command line tools
apis
and we believe sql not because we love
sql because everybody knows it
and to approximately have it feel like a
serverless system i connect to my data
infrastructure
i give you a chunk of sql
i activate my pipeline
and i'm done
right like it should feel like that
you know and i think that if
and and that necessitates and implies
like a cloud native experience right
like we will handle the scaling we will
handle job activation recovery and
messaging guarantees like all these
other kinds of things
you know from from the developers expect
uh perspective
excuse me
this is
the same as working with a cloud native
database system you know like where they
just sort of hand us a query and tell us
what to connect to
and we will take care of all the details
and that includes
you know dealing with sort of all the
failure cases dealing with all this you
know making schema changes safe dealing
with
you know
replay of data when something goes wrong
dealing with malformed data and like all
these other kinds of complex cases
that people build lots and lots of
infrastructure around i mean the
streaming world in a lot of ways
is like the hadoop world circa 2010
super low level
it's lots of lego bricks
and you know we're trying to you know
give people the the map that shows them
like how to you know properly stitch
those lego black bricks together
um and in a lot of cases do it for them
um so that they simply don't have to
worry about it without taking away
the flexibility to do right the the
really complex stuff you know because
like occasionally like there are things
you can't do in sql you need to do
low-level java imperative code or scala
or c plus or whatever
you know so like you know our view is
that the open source community has
established these de facto standards you
know protobuf or avro serialization json
whatever over kafka topics or kinesis or
these days that you have systems like
vectorized io and like all these other
kinds of things that are really exciting
you know
so there's like a natural
way to integrate with custom code
um
over time i think those custom code that
custom code actually feels like lambda
functions you know like effectively like
here's code that is agnostic to
streaming and messaging guarantees that
you sort of plug in like a user user
defined function like a udf
and we will sort of stitch it into the
larger pipeline just as you would
anything else
and it's riding on de facto messaging
systems with de facto serialization so
that
you're not stitched into this
proprietary system if you want to
integrate and pump that data into any
downstream system or source it from any
upstream system
like you know you don't have to worry
about your data being sort of locked up
in something and so like the mission for
declarable is like dead simple real-time
pipeline authoring just like that's it
got it
yeah so you so that's a key value um
that you've articulated
through this conversation and obviously
in the founding of the company it's that
streaming just needs to be
much much more simple less complex well
what other what other values are there
that sort of go into the way you're
thinking about this problem would you
say yeah
you know
i mean streaming at least the part of it
that we're focused on which is more
about sort of like acquisition
transformation and sort of like
feeding and curating you know different
streams to down downstream systems
we call that data engineering or
real-time data engineering you know some
people talk about
event-driven architectures i think that
also makes sense stuff like that so like
all this is sort of adjacent sort of
related
um
if you squint
it's all just etl
right like
we've given it a fancier name we call it
data engineering these days but like
it's a prac it's approximately take data
from a place and do something to it put
it someplace else
um
but
i i think you know one is just like
simplicity you know simplicity
and pragmatism
right so so not simplicity when you
start removing functionality like you do
need to sort of maintain and support
those use cases but i think
you know
as much as possible
you know we're not necessarily trying to
make this accessible to like the
marketing or or sort of sales person
right like this isn't about sort of
analyst up leveling
the bi folks the ml folks like they have
those challenges yeah it still has to be
powerful it's still for engineers right
still for engineers so our target users
are application developers building sort
of event driven systems and data
engineers you know who are supporting
like ml folks and like those kinds of
people um
but you know so those two communities
nosql so like that's the level of
sophistication for sure
but i think it's got to be pragmatic
it's got to be simple it has to like
just work it's the phrase that we use
internally at decodable um our biggest
feature is that like when you say
activate on a sql statement it activates
and like does the right thing like
it's not it's not sort of fancy math
it's not
bells and whistles um
and i think but i think when you talk
about etl
you have to be open
you have to not get too wrapped around
the axle about
whether a system you're pumping data
into
is like potentially competitive with you
you know and like you know so like a lot
of people vcs in particular have said
like well what do you think about like
materialize and imply and rock set and
there's like all the you know these are
all these like really great you know
companies that are doing like real-time
data you know including like on the
stream and stuff like that and my
assertion is that like we love those
systems as much as anything else i'm
like yeah in the venn diagram of use
cases maybe there's some overlap we
actually don't care
you know so like our job is to help a
customer do whatever they need to do and
so
i actually don't view any of those
systems as competitive so like
materialize is building this like sql
real-time data warehouse kind of thing
and sort of it is adjacent we view that
as adjacent you know we're sort of happy
to pump system data into that so i think
openness has to be a core value of the
product got it
yeah anyway yeah that's super
interesting um because of the space that
the quotable will op will will um
possess or will occupy in the ecosystem
um i can see where openness is a big
factor yeah um so so let's go under the
covers a little bit um talk to us about
some of the
architectural
um design decisions besides the the
philosophical values that we sort of
talked about already what are some of
the more unpractical architectural
decisions you made in decodable that you
think are interesting or novel or um or
sort of conscious trade-offs that that
you went through when thinking about how
to implement this
i think one of the things fundamentally
is that we believe that this problem is
distributed not centralized and so
you have sources and sinks scattered all
over like different cloud regions maybe
even on-prem and maybe different cloud
providers if you're like a much larger
company and you have different teams
doing different things
and so we knew sort of from the
beginning this couldn't be sent all your
data to us and then like we sort of do
do the thing
um
with that data
so instead we actually took a play from
the software defined networking space
the sdn space the idea that there is the
thing you want centralized is the
control plane
you know the ability to like this is
where like we do query planning and sort
of you know uh uh
like job submission and and those kinds
of things and that's effectively central
but the data plane that actually runs
the connectors the streams and the
pipelines can actually be distributed
and can be multiple data planes running
in different like instances of the data
plan running in different places
and not necessarily like all the way
down to the edge like that's i think a
different kind of system so we're not
talking about like on device or anything
like that at least not yet like you know
but we're thinking like think
one data plane per
region in a cloud provider and so what
you actually have is the ability to
build pipelines that span data plans
because a lot of this is really about
like i said if you're an ad targeting
company or a retailer and you want to
bring in like click stream data from
you know all of your facilities all over
the world
you know and like you want to do
filtering and anonymization and stuff
within the region and then maybe you're
just pushing aggregates or distilled
data or cleanse data to a central
location
for analytics with like a snowflake or a
materialize or whatever you know
um in that instance
you have all these sort of data planes
that are fully distributed and like
parts of that data is sort of going to
the central place and so we took like i
said we just sort of like stood on the
on the shoulders of giants here and just
said like the networking world actually
has this you have switches all over the
place you program them from a central
control plane and the control plane is
out of the hot path you know kubernetes
mostly follows this like a bunch of
systems mostly following this
pattern
we just sort of used it at the macro
level it's not necessarily novel but i
but i think that it's important for this
kind of problem
um
and that's just about sort of like
architectural sort of like how the how
the system works
it also means that like we can think
about on-prem as just being another
instance of the data plane
you know with you know private
vpns to cloud providers and stuff like
that so we can do lots of fanciness
there
um
and once you have all that stuff
centralized you now have sort of
metadata which gives you like a central
place for like lineage and you know
schema management and curating you know
and managing streams and discoverability
and like you can actually do all that
centralized while having the sort of
infra the infrastructure decentralized
um
so so i think that that has been really
really important for us
uh and what and what what kind of team
did did you have to build to to
implement this like what sorts of i'm
interested in understanding the
composition of the roles and
um what types of engineers you sort of
look for
um that that were useful to you and in
building the early team
yeah so the team is still small today um
and and growing um we're hiring uh
but uh
these are
people who have built data platforms
right at sort of other companies and
application level infrastructure so you
know
most of i think what we have done to
date we're still very early on you know
uh
we were formally founded in january of
this year so you know uh i won't get
into a ton of details there's lots of
stuff we haven't announced but let's
just say that we're still sort of early
in our journey there um
uh
these are these are folks that we've
sort of hired who are just like really
stellar engineers around some of them
have like actual stream processing
engine level experience like they've
been working on the internals of things
like flank and um and you know those
kinds of things
um
a lot of them are just super talented
engineers that have come from either
using these systems or building sort of
like larger data platforms at all kinds
of companies
um
both internal systems and like as
vendors like enterprise software vendors
for other people um but i think it's
probably a lot of distributed systems
type yes um folks hanging out at dakota
bowl i'd imagine yeah yeah absolutely um
people who get excited about messaging
guarantees and distributed systems
problems and quorums and consensus and
stuff
but but who care very much about
developer experience and and sort of
you know want to
want to make life a little bit easier
for folks
got it
um well i want to come back to the to
the question the topic that you brought
up earlier sort of the
like what's the future of data look like
in regards to
batch and stream coexisting together i
mean yeah you know we spoke offline and
of course um
you you are of the belief that um
that real-time data is going to unlock
new use cases um and new new analytics
opportunities and
improved business decisioning and
all kinds of things
so you you firmly believe that that
faster data is better
than slower data
and and i think from our conversation so
far your argument is that the only thing
preventing companies from harnessing the
power of real-time data is technical
complexity which you're trying to solve
at decodable um yeah
but still like sort of going forward you
know in in the world because we're all
pragmatists here um there's lots of
batch systems that are already in
existence not everybody's going to
convert their stuff over to streaming
immediately um if ever you know what
what does sort of the the future look
like in in eric hammer's mind regarding
the the interplay between batch and and
stream going forward
yeah i mean i think that the right
answer here is
you know is multiple
engines or run times you know batch
streaming
um
and
a single sort of api and programming
interface i think flink and spark and
google's cloud data flow like have been
doing this now at sort of a lower level
i think we need to up level that
you know some of these systems have
are either in the process of doing it or
have already done it i would argue that
there's still stuff missing there but
whatever you know i think
here if a developer can write a sql
query once
and have that approximately work whether
the source is batch
you know or
streaming source i mean there's complex
sort of stuff there about sort of time
and window functions and all these other
kinds of things but for the most part
you know if you can build those kinds of
things once
and
not worry too much about where it's
going to be deployed i actually think
that that's high value so like we talked
to a customer who's doing a building
like a feature store for you know a
bunch of ml engineers to sort of build
on top of
and the ml engineers know how to define
feature
features in terms of sql
and i'm like well look you can take that
same chunk of sql and run it in
decodable and like now
your offline training and your online
scoring and sort of evaluation is the
same
it's the same sequel you don't have to
worry about sort of like accidentally
building the feature the wrong way and
everybody's like oh my god like of
course that's the right way to do it and
so
you know
i don't know that it's perfect like the
exact copy paste sql works in this
instance it did but you know
um obviously there are more complex
cases but i think that
you know
developers just shouldn't have to worry
about that dichotomy we as as systems
builders um as engine people should
should pave over that complexity as much
as possible and i think that people are
doing that you know i think that you
know you look at the landscape and you
know we've talked about a bunch of names
i think we're working on that there you
know i know google is working on it
there's a bunch of i
you know i know snowflake is working out
there's a bunch of people working on
that um
you know
but
you know i think that there will always
be
times where you actually want to target
streaming versus batch you know for a
variety different reasons um
you know many of which have to do with
sort of data sovereignty and sort of
gdpr compliance
or even just like cost savings i don't
want to push stuff out you know i don't
want to pay for network egress on data
that can actually be sort of aggregated
locally or sort of distant locally
um
yeah so so so coexisting going forward
um
with hopefully a common api
that data teams can use to sort of throw
out a
at a dual uh dual home system if you
will yeah um you mentioned right you
mentioned also um sort of through the
the canonical example that
you know some developers
have a hard time getting their head
around is basically like throwing sql at
a stream um
and so you know maybe the last technical
question for you but how do you guys
handle that in a way that might be
different or comparable to how
materialize handles that considering
joins and um you know other sort of
complications there do you have a
fundamental
approach that's unique or novel and how
you handle that in decodable
yeah i mean
you know
i won't claim to be an expert on anybody
else's product i mean we sort of try and
be as
educated as possible but
you know a lot of these etl
style queries versus analytical style
queries
flex different portions of sql and so
we've focused more on
the
you know
part transform
you know filter like those kinds of
things and so
you know i'll level with you like we
don't see a ton of join right you know i
mean like you do for enrichment use
cases but
you know um
we definitely don't see people joining
streams we see people doing unions over
streams but like joins of streams
it's just um
it's just not super
common
um
and people talk about that as being like
a hard thing to do and like you know
bless the materialized folks they know
what they're doing over there okay
they have done a really great job on
sort of being correct
in you know joins and sort of real-time
analytics and isolation of queries and
like all sorts of other stuff
um
i you know i've talked to the team there
you know once you know in in passing and
and like they know what they're doing
there um that's why i think we're
complimentary i think like if you're
doing sort of real-time serving style
stuff like you know we are just not
going to be that system we're just not
going to be that i think materialize is
totally going to be that system
you know or at least one of them um on
the other hand like you know having the
power sort of being like fully
distributed and stuff like that i think
is is sort of a feature that we have i
think it pairs nicely with materialize
right
same skill set same persona you know two
sides of the same coin
um
you know at least at least in my mind
got it yeah that's helpful um thanks for
that
well um eric it's been a great
conversation i just want to like leave
you with a
final question um what's surprised you
most
about your work in the data ecosystem so
far
uh
wow that's a it's a good question
uh
i
uh i think um
we spend like 80 percent of our time on
things that only hit corner cases right
like
unlike the corner cases it turns and we
sort of miss
the forest for the trees i think the
thing that surprises me is
just how far like good enough
data infrastructure gets you i won't i
won't make fun of or pick on any one
particular technology but like i have
seen some technology that sort of
ignores some of the really hard stuff
like the corner case stuff be wildly
successful
and
you know it's the vhs beta thing like
you know
i think that has like
repeatedly caught me off guard it's like
wait a minute how do you handle this and
like well we don't who cares right
nobody gets that and i'm like oh my god
so like i think i think we could do
with a real good shot of pragmatism
in data infrastructure not that we
shouldn't solve those problems they are
important just that like
we should think about how people
actually use these systems versus
chasing sort of the technical purity of
of certain
certain domains
got it
um well we're certainly excited to see
decodable when it is is generally
available
um you've already offered on the show to
talk to engineers founders um
streaming affection autos
people who are stumped by streaming or
or sort of blocked internally
how can people sort of learn more about
decodable if they're interested and or
contact eric
so uh absolutely
um
check out
decodable.com
to there isn't a lot there we've we're
in sort of a private beta right now we
we occasionally increase capacity and
take on more folks so please sign up for
that private beta if you're interested
we expect to do a public beta i'll just
say soon
um you know uh but uh you know please
sign up for the newsletter and sort of
like sign up for our private beta as
well if that's interesting
we'd love to talk to you otherwise um
get in touch with me i mean like you
know
i think people can just email me right
uh esammer
uh at decodable.com
just just email me directly and like i
would love to meet with anybody to talk
about any of these topics
awesome well i'm sure folks will find
you on twitter um
yeah you're active there as well um yeah
is it uh esamer or i'm sure they can
just find find you by your name
it's just esamer yeah yeah great summer
in all places
awesome great well um eric it's been
great to have you here thanks for taking
the time to chat with me it's always a
pleasure to hear your thoughts
um especially surrounding streaming and
where we're headed so we can't wait to
see what you release with decodable and
good luck with that i appreciate it pete
thanks it's uh it's always a pleasure
man
uh thanks to our listeners for joining
us as well we'll have more awesome dc
thursdays coming up in future weeks
and uh the next episode specifically is
on
october 28th we'll be chatting with todd
person who's the co-founder and ceo of
era software um todd's a former founder
of influx data
and he's the time series expert in the
community so we'll be
enjoying a conversation with todd on
october 28th so don't forget to
subscribe
hit the bell icon to get notifications
and we'll see